good evening and welcome to planning
committee of statford on aen District
Council my name is councelor Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this evening some
housekeeping to start with uh we don't
have a fire alarm planned so if it does
go off please make your way uh to the
exits and the must point is the car park
across the road by the park uh sorry by
the pub um please make sure your phones
are off or at least in silent mode so
they don't disrupt the flow of the
meeting this is a meeting in public not
a public meeting so only those
registered to speak are permitted to do
so um I'll call those forward at the
appropriate time and give further
instructions then uh the meeting will be
recorded and is being broadcast on our
website and YouTube I believe uh oh
sorry I'll now introduce our top table
um from democratic Services we have Cara
Keller our Lister this evening is Sue
Mullins our planning manager is Alice
cosnet and our planning officers are
Stuart mckyer and Sarah flairty and I
believe Alice has a statement she's
prepared thank you chairman my role is
to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision
taking thank you very much okay we can
now move on to the agenda then uh item
one apologies for absence we have
apologies from councilors Eden Holmes
Keith Le and Ostrander
thank you very much uh item two
disclosures of interest I'm happy to
start I've had
Communications um from members of the
public and
CPR uh with regards to
item
uh four um I believe those were
circulated to other members as well so
that' be a blanket dispensation any
further disclosures Council Parry hello
and good evening chair um I'm the ward
member for application number 23
SL
slfu so I we be stepping down from the
panel this evening and speaking as the W
member thank you very much councilor
Harvey um I was one of the four members
who paid the site visit this afternoon
to the site of application number five
item number five and I've also on my own
visited to the site of application
number four thank you thank you very
much yes I was also a member on thats
side visit uh and councelor H serif in
as well and councelor Parry very good um
any further disclosures no very good in
which case we can move on to item three
minutes uh we've got minutes from
meeting held on the 10th of January
20124 um take everyone's had opportunity
to read them make sure they're an
accurate
record
um all agreed aged Johny good thank you
very much okay we can now move move on
then to item four which is our first
application or applications uh both held
at the same time we are looking at items
22485 ful and
22486 F uh Land north of Oak Road
Southwest of L Compton uh stent m is our
planning officer and when you're ready
take it
away
yeah thank you chairman uh the
application site is land north of Oaken
Road Southwest of L Compton uh members
may remember this application was heard
at committee uh in May last year and was
deferred to enable the assessment of the
needd design of the proposed buildings
by an independent AG agricultural
consultant and to enable the submission
of photo montages which show the
proposed buildings in situ to the
landscape uh to make things clear I'll
be doing one presentation but for two
applications at the site one application
is for the erection of agricultural
grain store with hardstanding access and
Associated works and the other
application is for the erection of
agricultural store Barn uh with
hardstanding access and again Associated
works so we have the um application site
at a small scale uh you can see the
application site denoted by the black
dot Southwest of L
Compton uh and then again we have
another locational drawing showing the
application site outlined in red uh you
can see that it's uh encompassed by a
field uh and you have a proposed access
which is running adjacent to the
field uh to the north of the site you
have a footpath which runs roughly um
east to west and and then to the east of
the application site there's another
foot path which runs north
south uh so this is the proposed site
plan uh illustrating the buildings uh
sighted next to one another to the
northern edge of the field uh you can
see there is uh existing tree line which
forms uh the boundary of the field to
the North and then towards the bottom of
the slide you've got uh just an
elevational drawing there showing the
building
things uh and here we have the proposed
grain store
plans uh materials consist of dark
stained Timber clad walls a corrugated
non-reflective metal roof so the eaves
will be uh 7 m high with a rid at 9.5
M and then we have the propo proposed
straw bar plans uh again dark stain
Timber clad walls uh corrugated uh
non-reflective metal roof uh Eaves at 7
meters in height with a ridge at 8.3
meters uh so we move on to um some site
visit images so this is taken from the
field entrance at Oak Road looking north
towards where the buildings would be
cited uh you've got a map an arrow here
just to the side of the slide which
hopefully illustrates the direction of
the image um you can see that the land
uh descends gently to the Northeast and
you can just about make out the
vegetation form in the northern boundary
of the
field so this is another Sol photo from
the western edge of the field uh
hopefully again the map in the Arrow
show um where the where the photo is
taken from uh again you can see the the
land generally descends towards the
Northeast um uh and you can just about
make out the head a hedge row broken
hedge row which is to the south of the
buildings which is denoted on the map
here and then we have this site photo is
taken from the east of the
buildings uh looking West uh you can see
the existing trees and vegetation which
form the northern boundary of the
field uh and then we move on to another
site photo so this is taken from the
foot path to the north of the uh
application site looking South towards
where the buildings will be cited uh you
can see that the land uh descends
steeply as you head towards the North
and you can just about make out the top
of the existing trees which again form
the northern boundary edge of the
field uh so this site photo is taken
from the roll right stones looking
Southeast uh sorry uh to the southeast
of the site looking Northwest towards
the application site again which is
denoted by the black
dot and then we move on to the
applicants photo montage which was
requested by members uh last year's
committee uh so this is taken from
Viewpoint two from the applicants
lvia um which is uh the adjacent public
foot paath um looking Northwest towards
the application
site uh and this is uh photo monage view
point2 but this is at year one uh with
the buildings in sichu which you can see
there and this is photo montage v.2 at
year 15 with uh mature vegetation um
screen in the building
uh and then again we go to uh the
applicant photo montage so this is uh
view.
6 um which is taken from the western
edge of L Compton about 1.2 kilometers
Northeast of the site looking
Southwest uh and this is as
existing and then we have the photo
montage uh sorry um at year one and you
can uh just make out the buildings
there and then we have uh 2.6 at year
15 with the building screen by the
mature
vegetation uh so in summary it's
considered that PR building is required
to REM meet the agricultural need
created by the expansion of arable land
at Ashby farm and whilst the proposed
buildings will be visible from some
views from the adjacent footp foot
paaths and Glimpse longer distance views
from the wider landscape overall the
effect of the on the land on landscape
character is considered to be limited
and not significant as such the proposed
development is considered to comply with
the relevant provisions of the core
strategy and NDP and therefore and is
therefore recommended that plan and
permission is granted please seize the
the update sheet for updates thank you
chair thanks J okay we now move on then
to our first speaker who is counselor
Simon Bing of long Compton Parish
Council good
evening uh so you've got three minutes
it's uh the button on the right hand
side to uh turn on the microphone I'm
happy to give you a 30 second warning uh
before your time's up and otherwise when
you're already feel free to take it
away
good evening please may ask that you
look at the pictures being shown whilst
I speak the proposed site sits in the
Cotswold natural landscape on the ridg
line above the village of L Compton I
hope that since the last committee
meeting considering this application
you've all visited the site and the
surrounding area to understand the
visual impact these applications will
have if granted whilst longan Compton
Parish Council acknowledged the
principle of development given by the
agricultural need of the applicant it is
questionable as to whether this
application is necessary or reasonable
in its current form the buildings as you
can see from the photographs will be
clearly visible from nearly all aspects
of the village and surrounding area
including the English heritage site at
the roll right Stones the buildings will
be significant in their prominence in
the landscape being on the ridge line
and this goes against policy one of the
long Compton neighborhood development
plan whilst we acknowledge that there
are other barns along this escarment
they are all set into the landscape and
not on the ridge as can be seen in the
photos the lvia sets out that the
existing hedgeline of matured trees will
shield the site from from view but as we
all know trees are only in leaf for a
proportion of the year and so in the
autumn and winter months this shielding
would not be present a recent planning
appearal in L Compton for sighting of a
dwelling building associated with
agriculture has been dismissed not least
for its effect on the character and
appearance of the landscape I quote the
planning inspectorate the surroundings
of the site consist of gently Rolling
Hills in an agrarian landscape with an
intermittent open character and
expansive views particularly towards
redcliff Hill the character is reflected
in the pastoral Lan veil of the cords a
andb landscape character assessment 2002
dark skies and the absence of lighting
also contribute to the rural character
of the area accordingly the landscape is
highly sensitive to change additional
Landscaping at the site boundaries would
help to mitigate against the visual
impact of the pro proposal however such
screening cannot be relied upon
particularly in winter months when
foliage is reduced and nor can it
survival in the longterm be guaranteed
moreover public views of The Proposal
will be obtainable from the rising
topography in particular the public
rights away around redcliff Hill as such
the extent of landscaping necessary to
screen such views of The Proposal would
itself appear harmful and out of place
this site sat outside the village
boundary and in the valley if this site
was deemed to be detrimental to the
character and appearance of the area the
sighting question here being on the
bridg line of an escarment surely would
even be even more so in relation to the
construction of the straw Barn it is my
professional opinion and experience that
straw Barn that is erected for the
intention of keeping straw ha and
Machinery is an open fronted B with
cladding on three sides and a hardcore
base an example can be seen in the
photos it is not necessar reasonable for
it to be fully cladded and have a roller
shutter
door the proposed site is nearly a
kilometer from the entrance to the
applicant's land and there's no hard
track to the site capable of taking
hgvs without the installation of the
track to these buildings nothing will be
done to reduce vehicle movements from
the site in fact quite the opposite as a
farm manager of over 5,000 Acres it's in
my professional opinion I cannot see how
this application its current form will
benefit the applicant more than if the
buildings were cited close to the
highway on their
land thank you very much uh members do
we have any questions for our Parish
Council representative this
evening no nothing forthcoming in which
case thank you very much for your
contribution
okay our next speaker then is Matthew
Chadwick agent for the
applicant good
evening uh so yes you also have three
minutes I'm happy to give you a 30
second warning and uh when you're ready
take it away great thank you very much
good evening members and thank you for
the opportunity to speak this evening my
name is Matt Chadwick I'm a senior
planner for John Phillips planning
consultancy and we the Agents of the
applications I'd like to thank officers
for their thorough report which
comprehensively cover offers all of the
relevant material
considerations you'll likely recall that
committee previously considered the
applications last May when they were
recommended for approval by your
officers however the matter was deferred
as members asked for an independent
review of the Agricultural need for the
buildings visualizations were also
requested in order that the visibility
of the buildings could be better
understood the requested assessment by
an agricultural assessor has been
undertaken confirming the buildings to
be needed the assessment also confirms
the buildings to be of appropriate size
and design to meet that need the only
query raised by the assessor was
regarding ventilation for the straw Barn
following clarification for the
applicant the assessor confirmed the
building to be suitably ventilated and
fit for purpose we believe this
independent endorsement should give the
committee confidence to approve the
applications the applicant has also
supplied visualizations of the proposed
buildings as requested by the committee
the supplied images allow comparison of
views prior to development one year
after completion and after 15 years when
land caping has matured it's important
to stress that these images are verified
views prepared to strict technical
standards to offer visualization of the
highest veracity they confirm your
officer's conclusion that the buildings
will not be harmful to the agricultureal
landscape we consider with these images
and the landscape and visual impact
assessment which accompan the original
application the applicants taken all
reasonable steps to demonstrate the
developments can be accommodated in the
landscape similarly the council has gone
to exceptional lengths to ensure the
special character of the landscape is
maintained deal ently discharging its
Duty your officer's report assesses all
relevant issues and confirms that
proposed development will not cause harm
including to the aom it also concludes
the bars can offer benefits to the rural
economy the positive recommendation is a
result of constructive work between the
applicant and Council as encouraged by
the mppf to provide a proposal which
allows necessary development to be
undertaken while protecting the special
character of the
area we wholeheartedly endorse your
officer's recommendation the application
to be approved and respectfully request
that the committee grants Planning
Commission today and I thank you for the
opportunity to speak thank
you thank you very much well within your
time uh members do we have any questions
for our agent Council Perry
first thank you and good evening um I
wonder if you can explain for me um the
rationale behind choosing the location
of the buildings so prominently on the
on the ridge line that was highlighted
by the previous speaker
particularly when you say you've
overcome all the special um landscape
issues in terms of the character of the
area yeah uh thank you for the question
um so I think the uh the visualizations
are very useful in showing that from the
closest public footpath they would be
visible but not particularly visible and
that's only in the immediate short term
within 15 years they're going to blend
into the kind of land landscape like
you'd expect buildings to uh of of of uh
farm buildings to to do so um and when
taken the view from the village which is
from the Northeast you you can see them
on the ridg line but they're not
prominent at all I think when you you'd
struggle to see them on that image
particularly after any amount of time
when they've blended into the landscape
when you've allowed the Landscaping to
mature so um this was one of the you
know other sightings were chose were
considered throughout the Farms holding
but this was the more discreet sighting
um and I think the visualizations show
that they're not going to be prominent
and that agricultural burnings are a
feature that you do see within the kind
of within the rural landscape and uh the
cot old um uh a andb advisor hasn't
objected to proposals
either if I could just um follow up can
you just confirm the distance from the
public footpath to these
buildings please I off the top of my
head I'm not totally sure it's oh it's a
couple hundred M the first Viewpoint was
about it does say on the um uh on the
visualization off top head it's about 2
300 M and the second one which is the
one taken from the village is I think
it's 1.2 km
away any further questions forent counc
pton thank thank you chair good evening
thank you um the parish council I think
their key issue is around the impact on
the and I'm not going to I think that's
for further discussion and debate but
there were a couple of other elements
the parish council had raised as as have
as of concern so one of those Taps Into
the Dark Skies policy and a request for
no external lighting
um in terms of is there a requirement
for external Lighting on the building I
couldn't quite see that there was
anything in there but um if we were if
the committee were minded to be granting
um an ex a condition around external
lighting how would that fly as far as
your your client is
concerned yeah thank you for the
question um no external lighting is
proposed in the application I um having
read the um officer's report it's um it
said that external lighting could be
conditioned if if um if that was
considered a necessary condition to
impose at the moment nothing is proposed
um and the um it's got the buildings
have translucent roof panels to allow
light in but given their use there's
going to be very little light emitting
from those buildings so okay and I have
a second question if I may uh on in a
similar vein uh the parish council also
have concerns about routing of vehicles
and I can see on page 16 of the officers
report that you your client did indeed
um provide a routing plan which would
seem to indicate that the that your
client themselves would not be averse to
a routing plan uh the County Council has
made a comment about the enforceability
and and this was a question raised in a
previous committee meeting but given the
um would I would I be correct in my
assumption that again were the were the
committee minded to uh look at some
routing plan that you're client would
not be averse to that on the basis that
they'd already provided a plan
themselves and so a condition along
those lines would not be problematic for
them would that be fair to say yes I
believe that would be fair to say I
suppose it's for committee to decide
whether it's whether it meets the tests
um but yeah having provided it they're
they're willing for that to be to be
included as a condition if if uh if it
meets the
tests thank you uh councelor Parry do
you want to come back in sorry yes I did
wanted to come back in when you um
highlighted the
screening um and it was highlighted on
the presentation that after 15 years can
you explain the sort of um height of the
vegetation of the planting that you that
would be done and why can't it be far
more mature from year one year two 15
years um I don't think I'll be here in
15 years sadly but you know 15 years is
a very very long time for a village to
put up with um a blot on on on the
ridge ridge line so why is the screening
not going to be more mature say within
five years an investment should be put
into that in that in that way um I think
the so the images are shown as it is now
within a year to show you know within a
year screening will grow slightly but
it's not going to grow great deal but
then the 15 years I suppose is is a
longterm view of it to see how it's
going to appear in in the not in the
short term but in the kind of
medium-term future um the screening will
grow quicker than that um I think it's
just a common thing with these kind of
visualizations that they show what the
situation is now what it will be in the
very short term so you can visualize
that and then what it's going to be in
the longer term the screening will grow
quicker and obviously it's going to be
it's not going to be that mature within
a year as the images show but it will be
more mature than it's not going to take
15 years for everything to grow but I
think that's just a common way of
showing it so you can visualize how it
would be in the kind of mid medium to
longer
term any further questions for our
agent no in which case thank you very
much for your
contribution okay we'll move on to our
final speaker who Ward member councelor
Wally hoggins good evening
councelor so you yes you have five
minutes happy to give you a 30 second
warning I am deeply concerned that I am
sitting before you again this evening
regarding a planning application for for
one of the most sensitive areas in the
Stratford District dist the pictures
being shown demonstrate just how
sensitive this is the proposal before
you is for agricultural barns allegedly
for the purpose of grain and straw straw
straw storage that the applicant will
use for this land and other land that he
Farms some distance away whilst I would
not dream of questioning the
justification for needing a barn for
these agricultural purposes I do
question the need for these barns to be
positioned in such a highly sensitive
part of the landscape on the ridge line
as far away from the access road as is
possible to get without actually
tumbling over over the precipice but in
a p position which in residential terms
will be very highly desirable often at
this committee we see procedure being
followed and regrettably procedure has
dominated this application rather than
resolution the parish council been clear
that they would be agreeable to a bar by
this applicant in a less sensitive
location and have even provided proposal
pictures in a location which would
minimize the impact on the landscape and
be less damaging in this highly
sensitive area of the countryside the
proposed Barn is one kilometer away from
the road I know this because I've walked
it the proposed alternative site is just
a few meters away from the road and
would not be a potential reminder of
process gone mad but rather those
involved in planning seeking resolution
instead of causing conflict amongst
local residents and damage that will
last for many lifetimes I am dismayed
that this applicant has not sought to
meet with either myself or the parish
council in order to seek a solution to
needing a barn and you know what I would
have said if he had approached have a
bar with our blessing just put it near
the road but not one on a site which
will permanently disfigure this cotwell
area of outstanding natural beauty in
perpetuity not getting in touch implies
that this was less about the barn but
more about the location for a structure
that was most desired because everyone
knows as night follows day that bars
with poor access often become redundant
and can then become dwellings by
following the class Q regulations I
therefore ask this committee to protect
this precious rural landscape and refuse
this application if you need reasons to
do this then refer should be made to
planning application
22716 which has just had an appeal
rejected this appeal refers to a site
that is visible from and to the
application being considered today the
inspectorate rejected the application
for many reasons but particular regard
was given to the appearance and
protected character of the landscape the
inspector stated that the landscape is
highly sensitive to change he also went
on to enforce the fact that any
structures within the open Countryside
would harmfully conflict with a
surrounding rolling natural landscape
having an erosive effect on its rural
character the location of the the this
proposal will cause environmental harm
in perpetuity the planning team at the
cotwell national landscape consists of
1.4 equivalent full-time members and it
covers an area of hundreds of square
miles with regard to this application
they have advised planners of planning
protections that the cwal dayb has and
have provided information to assist with
planners in making the right decision
about this application
who need to protect the landscape from
this undesirable development these
protections have largely been ignored
which I am discomforted by I have a copy
here for you if you need to make
reference to them the 1.4 members of the
cotwell planning team have a not
unrealistic expectation that the vast
number of the planning team at SDC will
protect the small but very significant
portion of the cotwell landscape that
falls within its jurisdiction and
therefore protection and all that makes
it so special and so we are now at
Commission and this responsibility L
lies with you as the final line in
defense it really is a very special part
of the district and it really does need
you to protect it this is not a burden
of responsibility it is precisely why we
were elected and why you've been
nominated to be on this committee to
protect our district and to make the
right decisions about the environment
both for our residents and our visitors
so that they can work rest and play in
safety and in
health our rural areas are the green
lungs of our district by rejecting this
proposal you'll be standing shoulder
toosh shoulder with the planning
inspectorate and you will be on entirely
the same page as them using the same
reasons to reject a development as they
did only last week and they rejected any
of the mitigations that were offered I
therefore beseech you to reject this
proposal because of the harm it will do
for generations to come if a planning
inspector can reject proposals for
development in this highly sensitive
area then so can you and Vally I have
not seen any evidence of no objection by
the aonb and I am a member of the cotal
a board as appoint as appointed by this
District Council thank
you thank you very much councelor uh
well within your time members do we have
any questions uh yes counc H good
evening good evening thank you for that
am I correcting you saying that uh the
applicant didn't approach the parish
council at all no nor me nor you nor no
nor me nor the Paris Council no okay
thank
you thank you uh further questions yes
councelor
pton thank you can I just confirm that
the appeal decision you are you
referenced is land at Butler's Road l
Compton is
that right okay it's just so I can
understand because it's a it's one
that's been relatively recently
circulated to members so I just wanted
to clarify that thank
you very good any further questions for
a war
member no in which case thank you very
much for your contribution this
evening totally good okay we can now
move on then to points of clarification
from our officers any points
clarification members would like to
raise
har thank you chairman page 16 makes
reference to a net reduction in
vehicular movements have we got any
quantities on
that bear with we're just going to have
a look at that see if we can find that
thank you
so with without the grain store there
would be around 58 movements by tractors
and trailers between the farm uh farms
in a concentrate period and then with
the grain store this will reduce down to
uh 30
movements right so it's half
roughly second question
go in my experience which clearly I
don't live in long gton but my
experience of this site is most viewed
from people traveling south on the
a3400 which as you travel South you'd
see this amazing Vista
uh right across your your the front of
your windscreen it's quite an impressive
site um however I'm trying to establish
in my own mind whether the uh apex of
the roof of these structures proposed
structures would actually be seen from
that vantage point above the line of the
ridge or whether the height of the of
the buildings would actually be lower
than the actual
Ridge um my my perception at the moment
is that given the building is 9 meters
high and the contour lines that I'm
looking at refer to
250 I may sorry
225 plus 9 leads me to think that the
height of the ridge will be below the
ridge of the hill is that true or not
can you tell
me I think we can only really rely on
the photo montage which has been
provided which isight off which is off
the a3400 we don't have a photo montage
from the a3400 so I wouldn't want to
confirm or deny that to be the
case thank you any further points of
clarification yes councelor
padum yes thank you um I just wanted to
ask about um the conditions condition n
on page 17 it says it will be permitted
to shall be used solely for the purposes
of culture and should not be used for
any other purposes other than
agricultural operations is this
something that would work for the future
or is that literally just while they're
in
operation so that condition would be in
perpetuity okay that's great thank
you councilor pton next thank you
chair um the ward member
has
raised in addition to the the question
around the impact on the landscape and
has referenced a planning appeal
decision which members have had
circulated also raised the prospect of a
concern around the future viability of
the Agricultural buildings and the
potential risk through a class Q
application that this could become uh a
residential uh s
it what if
any
protection could we
reasonably and en forcibly
secure to guard against that were the
committee be minded to
Grant um so you'll note that Pages 17
and 18 provide the conditions for the
for the two permissions as recommended
so condition nine on both permissions
would restrict the use of the building
for agriculture so the effect of that is
that if they were to come in so so first
of all what I will say is they would
have to wait 10 years after the
building's been in place to apply for
class Q at that point um because we have
that condition on there in assessing the
class Q um we have to check that there
aren't any other conditions attached to
planning permissions on the site which
restrict their permitted development
rights essentially to change use under
class q and in this case how having that
agricultural use condition essentially
means that they fall foul of the
permitted development right in as much
as they wouldn't be able to benefit from
class Q consent um the reason being the
article three brackets four of the
general permited development order which
uh sets out class Q requires that in um
quoted nothing in this order I.E the
gdpo permits development contrary to any
condition imposed by any planning
permission granted or deemed to be
granted under part three of that act
otherwise than by this order so what
that means is a class Q would contravene
condition nine of the permission hence
it wouldn't be permitted
development can I just
explore um in terms of the condition it
talks about the purpose of Agriculture
and shall not be used for any other
purposes other than agricultural
operations I'm the farm manager I need
somewhere to live and I've got to make
sure I look at after the farm
um to what extent could we tighten
condition nine to avoid that particular
argument um and I and I and I and I know
I'm I'm I'm I'm looking down a rabbit
hole here however if we were minded to
Grant 10 years down the line somebody
could be looking at how we came to this
and testing the tightness of the
condition and I think if uh I I think I
I certainly would be looking for
something tighter I think there because
when I first read it agricultureal
operations could could mean anything and
could in could include workers on site
or a manager on site or could be argued
that that that could be
something um so I'm just having look at
our standard conditions that the list in
the in the uh agenda is kind of like a
pricey of what we would be looking to
attach so the standard condition would
most likely
require that it can only be used for the
purposes of
Agriculture um and in Brackets have
agriculture being defined and the
section 336 of the Town and Country
planning act 1990 as amended um so that
it's clear the definition of agriculture
obviously wouldn't include a residential
use
um an agriculture um the definition of
agriculture wouldn't include a
residential use even if it was a farmer
living there so we would make sure that
it that it was clearly just for for that
purpose what we could do is we could
agree if members are minded to Grant
agree the wording of that condition with
the chairman to make sure that he's
content that it is as strict as it needs
to be that the intention is that it's
only used for agriculture and not any
sort of residence in in association with
the
agriculture uh and then my final uh
question for of clarification uh comes
back to this question of a rooting
strategy and and and we indeed did
discuss a routing strategy and I
understand the County's view what we
appear to have is again were the
committee minded to Grant an
applicant um at least on the face of it
you know prepared to do the right thing
if you will um and whilst I accept
technically enforceability I'm not I
should we not try and assist an
applicant who wants to do the right
thing in at least
diminishing at least one of the concerns
that the that the that the community
have uh I think the key one is around
the impact of the building but if we if
if the committee gets past that the
question I would be certainly looking
for a for routing to be putting even in
the acknowledgement that it is you know
almost voluntary but there's at least
something there I just your
thoughts um so my view is is that
routing strategy are very difficult to
enforce um it's hard to tell where
vehicles are coming from and to and
whether they actually from the site as
as you know um what I will say is that
if members do consider a routing
strategy condition to meet the six
condition tests it's within your gift to
adds that condition my professional
opinion is that it it wouldn't meet the
the test the reason being that it's not
enforceable and that is one of the T six
test that conditions need to meet I I my
view would be as a compromise to add a
note on um to kind of cover it off now
we all know that that that's not
enforceable either but at least it sets
the tone when the the decision notice
that this is what is expected but like I
say that that's over to members to
decide thank you councelor
pattingham um the um
visualizations of the site uh shown by
the applicant were very different from
the visualizations that councelor H
hoggins showed um
uh can you uh in your professional
opinions um which ones are the most
realistic so the um photo montages have
been submitted by technical experts um
and are with the buildings are drawn to
scale so in our professional opinion
they would be um the most likely uh
representation of that's the applicants
on yes the the example of is one what's
on the screen at the moment yeah the
applicants photo
montages if I can just add um something
um obviously this this came to committee
previous meeting that those shadings
were indicative only they weren't to
represent the scale for the reason that
they haven't been properly verified
whereas the photo montages provided by
the applicant have been
right
so public rights of way they they seem
to be closer to the to the the bars than
um
than in terms of this or is it going to
be um I'm not an expert on the
guidelines for undertaking lvas because
they are quite complex guidelines
my generally um the two which have been
provided are both public viewpoints
aren't
they it's councelor
Perry thank you chair my concern relates
um obviously to the to the character of
the landscape and the
screening um we've now have brought to
our attention an appeal the decision was
only made last
Thursday where the inspector makes
reference to concern for a caravan not a
not huge Barn buildings but actually
makes reference to concern
on the mitigation screening can make
what I would like to know obviously
because this decision was has come
through last
Thursday the officers haven't been able
to consider the decision that was made
in this appeal in a similar area with an
impact on the character of the landscape
but equally important the inspector
makes um whilst he says additional
landscape on the siteb boundaries would
help to mitigate against the visual
impact of The Proposal which is for a
caravan for an Agricultural work such
screening cannot be relied upon we've
heard this evening um from the
applicants agent about a
landscaping plan where you know it's
going to take 15 year you know we've had
an example of 15 years I do have
concerns that we've had a serious
decision from an appeal within councelor
Perry can you just make come around to a
question concise for for offic my
concern is have the officers had the
chance to look at the
appeal because it's not in the report
obviously because the reports were
published
before the decision was taken my concern
is the weight we can therefore give to
the screening the landscap
escaping um and the decision that was
taken can we go to our officers so they
can respond thank you the office
actually the officers refused that
application so the inspector was fully
in line with how we determined the
application so there was nothing new in
the appeal decision that we weren't
already doing in terms of assessment so
there was there's all there was no need
to specifically relate to that
application and the assessment of that
application because we were already
considering those policies with the
exact same weight that the inspector did
what I will say is the proposal is very
different I know you've made reference
to it you've said you've implied that a
caravan's obviously smaller than
agricultural buildings but my advice
would be agricultural buildings are much
more sympathetic to a rural landscape
than a caravan so I think that's why
they're very different they're located
in very different parts that's to the
other side of L compon to this
application site so in essence I don't
think they're comparable coming back to
the screening point if I can I
completely agree I don't think it's
right to determine applications on the
basis of screening because it can't be
relied upon I think in my professional
opinion looking at the photo montages
the visual impact is acceptable at year
one when the screening isn't
significantly established so I don't I
think members can obviously have regard
to the screening I don't think they have
to rely on it I think they have to make
a judgment as to whether the visual
impacts of of the scheme in this context
are
acceptable okay thank you any further
points of clarification for our
officers okay in which case we can move
on to debate who would like to
start and we jump at
once counc Harvey thank you I'm quite
happy to start um this is an incredibly
sensitive site uh I have driven up and
down the a3400
for 60
years um I can remember the foot and
mouth outbreak in
1968 and the uh measures that were taken
along the a3400 known as the a334 at the
time so I'm I'm familiar with the site
it's a wonderful this and it's one of
probably one of the best in in the
cotwell we have to deal with the
application that's in front of us not an
application for a site that might be an
alternative
site we've got a Consultants report
which says these buildings are
agriculturally
Justified we've got no objections from
statutory
consules notably cotwell National
landscape have raised no
objection there's no objection from the
local Ramblers
the applicant has made a
significant effort to ensure that the
proposed buildings
are as camouflaged if that's the right
word as possible um I have my own view
about where I think it sits in relation
to the absolute Ridge but that's another
matter
um faced with either approving or
refusing um the negative way to put this
would be to say on what basis would we
defend an appeal given all the
information that we've
got given all the responses that we've
had given the evidence that we've
got I'm of the mind that we should go
with the officer's recommendation and
and
Grant thank you councelor is that a
proposal or just comment for this moment
if somebody else wants to propose propos
that's fine but I'm quite happy to
propose that's my view at the moment
okay thank you who would like to go next
in the debate c
passingham yeah I I think it's
disappointing that the applicant didn't
consider the uh the advice of the parish
council or talk to the parish council
about the sighting of the of the barns
however the the visual impact seemed
very very minimal to me from the public
right of way uh and if if as we told
these are realistic uh
visualizations I can't see that um we
can object on on visualiz on landscape
grounds so I um support the
application okay thank you very much uh
go
pemon thank you chair
um I've been looking at
the appeal
decision
um and whilst I didn't have a 60-year
Journey along the a34 I I know the route
well it
is as the appeal um decision talked of
um it is it is an important Vista and
View and the landscape is as described
in par uh Point 15 of the appeal
decision
the landscape is highly sensitive to
change um and
I'm even with screening in fact to some
degree the additional extra
screening in of
itself changes the Vista so we've got
this row of row of trees that were
behind and we're now going to have an
additional um set of
screening which is not natural in terms
of that Vista it's it's been put there
to serve a purpose and to my mind starts
to fundamentally change the Vista
because we're introducing something to
hide
um and whilst agricultural buildings is
absolutely right that they are more
harmonious
with an agricultural rural setting than
a
caravan
the at Paris 17 that you know the the
applicant the the inspector talks about
you know a a structure with a
utilitarian functional design well if
there's anything that's not ellar and
functional that that is because by
definition it has to be and I'm just
really really not
convinced that this is the right thing
in the right place given its impact I
absolutely accept that the applicant is
doing as much as it can I think it's a
finally
balanced decision as to whether its
impact and I think it becomes a
subjective thing about the impact and I
do not at all criticize officers for the
the Judgment they have come to I just
and I think probably before seeing the
before looking at that at that decision
on balance I probably would be ering
towards supporting officers but I think
we have an inspector's decision that is
looking at this general landscape and
its impact and is flagging to us that we
need to be really really really careful
about what we do and again I stress I'm
not critical of officers because I think
99 times out of 100 or even 999 out of a
th000 I'd be backing you all the way
I think the inspector orbe it's a
caravan it's not quite on all fours
there's enough in there for me to say
there is such sensitivity around this
particular landscape that we should be
really really really cautious and on
that
basis I am going to struggle to support
the officer's recommendation and I would
be turning towards the appeal decision
and it's and I'd be if I if we get to it
I'd be building reasons for refusal
around some of the issues raised in the
most recent appeal decision and again I
I take what the the the planning manager
has had to say but I think that um there
is there is some there is something in
that and and so for that reason um I
would be I would be not supporting
officers on this particular occasion um
I I I'll leave it for others on the
committee to consider uh and uh I I I
think it's a balanced and could be a
rational decision either way chairman
can I thank you um I'll go for Council
Harvey and then Council thank you thank
you chairman just on the specific point
Council pton raised about the screening
and whether it's deliberately there etc
etc I have in front of me an OS map
which is dated 2009 skin Flint that I am
um but it shows existing a line of trees
in exactly that spot so this is not new
screening this is old screening
on one hand you you'd argue there's an
enhancement of screening I think
perversely the you know that's that's
there in his natural that is part and
parcel of it we're introducing an an
additional level and it and to me I my
concern is it the screening in of itself
changes the Vista it's it's close to and
I I I absolutely abolutely accept you
could argue it's dancing on the head of
a pin um I've just got some concerns
around it and it may be that I find
myself in a minority on that and that is
I to say I think there is a rational
decision to go either way that but I
take your point that it's I I was trying
to talk about the screening that it gets
brought into play to support the
screening of the building itself is a
change to the landscape and I think this
that that itself is something to
consider thank you
uh thank you chair um yes this is a a
very finely balanced application in
front of us but I do feel that as a
planning committee we have a role to
protect our
heritage and the rural aspect of what
the district has um we are facing
continual proposals for solar Farms all
over the the district that are blotting
the landscape they go through because of
climate
change I think what's really really
important what I'm really concerned
about is protecting the landscape and
the character for my grandchildren to
see because if we're not careful we
won't have Vistas and opportunities to
have wonderful views because they'll be
cluttered for me the appeal decision
that was taken last Thursday
changes it it it brings a different
emphasis and for
me I'm going to propose we refuse on the
basis of the impact on the character of
the
landscape um I think it's a great shame
the applicant didn't Lia more with the
parish council to look at
relocating you know know the fact that
they're located literally a kilometer
away from the roads we're going to have
Tracks Of
Vehicles large
hgvs you know more consideration needs
to be made to protecting our
landscape that's it in a nutshell for me
I I I I want to protect our landscape
and I want to protect what we've
got once it's gone it's gone
and we can't do anything more about it
um and I do think this appeal decision
from last Thursday strengthens our case
because it gives a good example thank
you I'll just go to C hin and then counc
M thank you chair um I do have concerns
with this
application um for one as councelor
Parry has said the lack of uh
consultation with the parish council
that is imperative in my view um the
positioning of this building uh could
have been in a better place I don't see
why it has to be so far from the road at
all um so I'm leaning to supporting
councelor Parry on
this councelor pton chair I just wanted
to clarify whether councelor passingham
had actually seconded councelor Harvey's
proposal uh I'm certainly in the place
of seconding councelor parry's proposal
but I wasn't sure where we actually were
at and so I just yeah I think you're
right to clarify that at the moment
um there wasn't a proposal
chair so I I understood from what I
asked of uh coun Harvey that that was
taken as a proposal to Grant in line
with the officer recommendations
I said I was prepared to I I said you
can play back the record I said I was
prepared to propose if nobody else
wasn't if nobody else did I I was fine
so on that basis am
I am I right in assuming that then we
haven't had a proposal to Grant on the
officer's
recommendations
okay in which case we haven't had a
proposal to Grant therefore the only
proposal so far we've had is from
councilor Parry which is against officer
recommendations and I would be prepared
to second that I think there is probably
more debate to be had having said
that thank you for that Clarity at this
time councelor
Fleming um for me we've got um we keep
relying on this decision that happened
last Thursday and we've got the the uh
planning managers saying that
technically it's not relevant because it
was is a different type of application
it's in a different area and whatever so
I I'm in a situation where I kind of
agree with the people who say refuse but
at the same
time the the reasons that we're being
built on to make that refusal don't
stand up with the advice from the
planning manager so um so from that
perspective um my my sort of thoughts
are if if we refuse this and they don't
build these these barns to maintain Agri
culture what'll happen they'll turn it
into a flipping solar farm that's that's
my concern and that's even worse so from
that
perspective I live in a very rural area
where we rely on agriculture so from
that
perspective although it may well be it
may well impinge and in and impact the
landscape we are a rural area that
depends on agriculture so I I won't be
going against the officer's
recommendation at this time
thank you um I've been listening to the
debate and I wanted to sort of gather my
thoughts before I sort waited in myself
I think what council Fleming's just said
Has solidified my thoughts and I agree
with him very much I think it is
certainly um a finally balanced
application and that's been aired very
rightly so particularly in the landscape
um aspect of it I am very reticent to
rely heavily on the appeal decision that
was just heard and I think you Council P
um AED exactly why that that that was a
risk that the would be present in any uh
decision we made on that basis uh and
that um on the basis of what our
planning manager has said um I for my
part I do I do appreciate the
sensitivity is extremely sensitive
landscape but it is also a living land
landscape and we have to be aware of
that as well and these are agricultural
units not um res residential not
Caravans and I think that is pertinent
in my mind so on that basis I I would be
in favor of supporting the offic
recommendations uh now I I haven't done
the arithmetic in my mind as of yet but
we clearly have um a range of opinions
across um the members who have spoken so
far uh we do have um a proposal to go
against officer recommendations which
has been seconded I'm prepared to make a
proposal to go along with the officer's
recommendations uh and I would be
seeking a seconder
after looks like coun Harvey might be
willing to Second uh in which basis we
have two proposals the one that was
seconded shall be heard first which is
to go against officers recommendations
I'm happy to hear more from the debate
but clearly we've all aired quite a lot
already uh I'm just going to speak to
our officers very quickly before we
proceed
so the notes um I was taking firstly
while coun spoke and and councelor Parry
um if I start with Parry because I know
you propose so it's obviously the the
role to protect Heritage and the rural
aspect of the district um needing to um
protect the character of the landscape
and I think councelor pton made
reference to the important Fister and
view um the landscape is highly
sensitive to change I know um we talked
about screening utilitarian functional
design not convinc it's the right
development in the right place so what
I've taken from that is is the members
are or certainly the prop in the sector
are minded to refuse on the basis of
impact on landscape and don't agree with
the officers conclusions in terms of the
landscape and a so in terms of specific
policies I think um CS5 cs9 cs1 of the
core strategy and then we've got E1 of
the NDP which talks about preserving the
the skyline essentially so just want to
check that that's in line with your
understanding and the vote would be on
that basis brilliant thank you chairman
okay thank you uh thank you very much
everyone for that um would anyone else
like to contribute to debate before we
move to the vote I'm quite happy to move
to the vote yeah okay uh okay so and
just for clarity this is two
applications um both need a vote um but
I'm taking that the proposals and
seconds are for both applications
correct yes jolly good okay so the first
vote is
for uh ref sorry refusal of application
22485 f for the reasons just given um
from our planning manager can I see all
those in
favor
four can I see all those
opposed yeah
four okay um as chairman um I have the
casting vote in which case that
fails for
um we move on to the next one which is
um proposal to refuse application
22486 F can I see all those in
favor four and
opposed
four and uh same same result uh in which
case casting vote and that fails we now
move on then to the proposed Al to Grant
um application
f um for the uh in line with the
officer's
recommendations yes Council chair before
you go to the vote there was question
of discussion of negotiation with the
chair about the occupation condition and
there was the question of at least a
note around a routing strategy uh I I
can read the room but I think that U if
we could just make sure those things are
picked up thank you I welcome that
interjection Council pton um yes on that
particularly I um did identify um
condition nine um the wording to be
agreed with myself uh to be in line with
the the feelings of the committee to
restrict any further use of the uh the
buildings subject to a class C
application at the time um and as I also
noted um I think a note um with regards
a routing strategy is appropriate and
I'd seek to have that added on as well
which seems to be agreed by our planning
manager
okay uh can I ask if that was agreed by
my seconder Council Harvey it was jolly
good thank you very
much okay um in which case we can now
move on to um the vote for uh
recommendation to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendations for
application
22485 F can I see all those in
favor
for and against sorry four in which case
casting vote uh from myself is to Grant
uh and for proposal is to Grant in line
with the officer's recommendations for
application
22486 Fu can I see all those in
favor for and
against thank you very much uh in which
case casting vote and application is
granted so committee resolves to Grant
applications
22485 F and
2214 486
F uh in line with the officer's
recommendations thank you very much
everybody
we'll move on then everybody to our
final application which is item five
application
23/
02139 F bromson Hill Farm ashorn War um
our presenting officer is Sarah FY once
you're ready take it away
thank you chairman this is a full
planning application for the erection of
a replacement dwelling the application
site is located in an open Countryside
location near ashorn to the south of the
M4 40 and just off the
fway here we see a satellite image of
the site the existing dwelling can be
seen here denoted by the
arrow with agricultural buildings
associated with the farm located here to
the
Northeast
sorry the proposed site plan can be seen
on this slide a new access is proposed
here off the existing Farm access with
the parking area location here proposed
dwelling here and an area for a ground
Source heat pump located here the
existing trees seen on the site
boundaries are proposed to be
retained here we see the proposed floor
plans and elevations of the replacement
dwelling the dwelling will be 8.2 m in
height and would have four
bedrooms this image is taken facing
north up the driveway the existing
dwelling can be seen here behind the oak
tree with some farm buildings seen here
to the right
the proposed dwelling will be located on
the left of the image in front of this
fence this image is taken facing
Northwest and shows the existing
dwelling this application seeks to
replace one of the Agricultural
buildings serving the farm can be seen
on the right
here this final image is taken facing
from the access drive towards the
Southwest um the proposed delling would
be located on the right of the image um
with the knee driveway entering the site
just in front of this oak tree here
chairman there's a conflict with the
principal development with officers
finding that the proposal fails to
comply with policy cs20 and as10 of the
core strategy landscape harm has also
been identified contrary to policies CS5
and as10 the recommendation is therefore
to refuse the application for the
reasons detailed on page 29 of the
agenda pack and the updates in the
update sheet thank
you thank you very much Sarah okay we
can move on then to our first Speaker
who's councelor George Struthers of new
pc and ashorn Parish Council good
evening
counselor um you have three minutes I'm
happy to give you a 30 second warning
before your time is up uh it's the
button on the right to uh turn on the
microphone and when you're ready take it
away chairman councilors I'm George
Struthers current chairman of the newb
pacy and ashon Parish Council I should
also declare that my family and I are
amongst the closest neighbors to bromson
Hill Farm but I do not know the
applicant and have only met the current
occupant of the farm Mr Tim Morland on
one occasion and again tonight when
visiting with fellow counselors the
council undertook a site visit to
bromson Hall Farm on Tuesday the 22nd of
August
2023 and you are in receipt of our
deliberations dated 6 September
2023 I'm sure that you've all read the B
East I hope you have the concerns of the
parish counselor as follows the current
Farmhouse is in a very poor State and
needs to to be demolished it is also in
close proximity to a very large barn and
a very active working farm any farmyard
is a dangerous place as I'm sure you'll
appreciate especially for children with
three children under six the parish
council thinks it necessary that any
replacement dwelling should provide
sufficient distance to allow separation
from the working farm for both safety
and amenity for play during the building
of the new dwelling and after completion
this will enhance their physical and
mental
well-being the sighting of the new
building within the current without the
current curtilage is in the view of the
parish council Justified to fulfill the
needs of safety and Immunity bromson
Hill Farm is a busy modern farm which is
developing and should be assisted to do
so it deserves a mature a modern
Farmhouse and provision of solar panels
and uh uh Grand Source heat pumps will
add additional benefits in terms of
renewal energy with regard to Scenic
matters the parish council considers
that the construction of the new
dwelling will not adversely affect the
landscape nature of the area the farm is
bounded by the b4100 wark banry road to
the north whilst the farm is clearly
visible The Farmhouse is not and we
consider that the new Farmhouse will not
be also from the south the farm is
bounded by the road from the harbory
house roundabout to the ashon crossroads
I live to the south of the road I cannot
see the farm or Farmhouse I consider it
consider it unlikely that I will or
would be able to see the new Farmhouse
either any motorist traveling on this
road is unlikely in our view to see
either the house or the farm the only
sorry the only true perspective would be
produced by a drone which would reveal a
working farm and Farmhouse within the
Farmland that they are
managing this application has the the
full support of the newb pacy and ashon
Parish Council for the construction of a
new Farmhouse plus the demolition of the
existing farmhouse on behalf of the
parish council I commend this
application to you for your approval
thank you
chairman thank you very much well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our Paris Council
representative this
evening nothing forth coming in which
case thank you very much for your
contribution
okay we now move on then to our next
speaker who is Tim morand the
applicant good evening Mr morand uh so
you also have three minutes I'm happy to
give you a 30 second warning when before
your time's up otherwise once you're
ready take it away thank you good
afternoon chairman members of the
planning committee thank you for letting
me speak I'm the occupier partner in the
farming business uh which is owned by my
grandfather the land I'm pleased to not
the planners accept the principle of the
replacement dwelling
given the structural issues we have with
the existing dwelling I appreciate the
planners will wish to stick to the black
and white of the policy I'm a farmer who
wants to offer the best quality of life
for my young family I've got three
children under the age of six who enjoy
spending a lot of time Outdoors we've
made it a safe area for them to explore
and develop without worry of being able
to take yeah without worry of being able
them being able to get to the dangerous
working areas a few yards away including
installing a taller fence with small
mesh they cannot climb over to prevent
them from being able to come into the
working yard without
supervision we don't get a lot of family
time parks and days
out as Farm's busy leading to Long
irregular hours so they have lots of
toys entertainment outdoors and they can
come and go from the house by the front
door as they please safely and
securely while I accept that what I'm
proposing while I accept that what is
proposed the replacement dwelling is
outside of the residential curage policy
cs20 does not allow for this does allow
for this if there are environmental
benefits we Farm an excess of 700 cattle
produce a great deal of smells and noise
from the agricultural operations
currently the house is adjacent to the
farmyard with buildings are joining the
house the new house will
create sorry with buildings ad joinings
the house which creates many significant
environmental and health issues simply
moving the house a short distance away
will not help this positioning the house
in the proposed location will allow my
family and I to have a better standard
of living and benefit the health of my
children the development may take us
several years and I do not want the
safety and development of my children to
be affected from the loss of the garden
during the building
process Parish counsel and local counsil
has visited the site they've seen the
farming operations and they've both
understood my reasoning and agree that
the position offers substantial
environmental benefits over the existing
house the proposed location would still
remain close to existing farmyard as
such would be seen as part of this group
of buildings when viewed as a part of
the wider
landscape the report of the planning the
report to the planning committee draws
attention to the size of the red line
please note this was a requirement by
the council in order for our application
to be validated rather than something we
proposed to maximize the use of
renewable energy Technologies the new
house will allow us to use ground Source
heat pumps and solar panels
and along with the upgrades and building
materials this will allow us to be
self-sufficient as part as most
self-sufficient as
possible at the request of the of the
planning officer a tree survey was
undertaken and avoided to avoid damaging
or mutilating trees we move the position
of the pro dwelling to the position now
being discussed whereas building in the
garden would require the removal of
trees and shrubs that are valuable the
pr I I'll ask you just try and wrap up
that
thank you very much yeah sorry s thank
thank you very much for your um if you
stay seated just for a second I'm just
going to see if any of our members have
any questions for you uh councelor
Harvey good evening Mr and I I'm going
to would you indulge me a moment I'm
going to read to you a piece of um what
some people regard as planning gobble
deuk but I want you to listen carefully
this is taken from as10 the policy that
deals with country side and
Villages and it reads the following
forms of development and uses in the
countryside are acceptable in principle
and then one of them is paragraph I a
permanent dwelling for occupation by a
person engaged in an agricultural
operation or other form of use that can
only reasonably be carried out in the
countryside subject to a functional need
being established does that describe
you uh yeah I think it probably does
thank
you thank you any further questions for
applicants no I don't believe so in
which case thank you very much for your
contribution this evening thank
you okay we'll move on then to our final
speaker W member councelor Parry good
evening
councelor uh you five minutes again
happy to give you a 30 second warning
but uh once you're ready take it away
thank you chair and thank you members I
am fully in support of this application
for the following material planning
reasons there is no harm to the
character of the area and the proposed
location site for a new replacement
dwelling is not visible from any
neighboring Properties or the highway
and therefore Accords with
CS5 the proposal conforms to cs9 in
respect of its design and
distinctiveness as the proposed new
replacement dwelling would enhance the
sense of place and reflect the character
and distinctiveness of the
locality policy cs20 advises that
replacement dwellings are not
inappropriate providing the existing
dwelling is not considered suitable for
attention a site visit and inspection of
the existing property this afternoon
will have provided committee members
with the evidence that the building is
not fit for purpose nor able to be
refurbished in view of the failing
structural condition as confirmed by the
structural report the applicant provided
the proposed dwelling reflects a
reduction in its built form of 23 square
meters and therefore as a replacement
dwelling would not be causing
inappropriate harm to the character of
the area or to neighboring properties as
permitted according to policy as10
paragraph f
the proposed new dwelling Accords with
CS2 and includes renewable energy from
sources of solar panels and a ground
Source heat pump providing a significant
reduction in carbon
emissions the replacement dwelling at
bromson Hill Farm Accords with cs1 and
is therefore a sustainable development
in line with the
mppf whilst it is acknowledged that the
location for the proposed replacement
dwelling is adjacent
to the residential curtilage of the
existing dilapidated Farmhouse it is
essential that consideration is given to
the overall planning balance in respect
to this
application for the aforementioned
policies and also due to the following
significant
issues it would be totally inappropriate
to demolish the current farmouse and
place replace with a new dwelling which
abuts the working agricultural Farm
buildings in view of significant
environmental and health issues
affecting a very young family the
location of a replacement dwelling close
to agricultural buildings used for
cattle and feed storage at a highly
active working farm that expels
continuous and significant noise and
odors represents a totally inappropriate
living
environment locating the living
accommodation a short distance away from
the working farm would create a much
improved living environment for the
farmer and his very young family it
would also enable the farmer to expand
his agricultural business and increase
the size of his livestock and storage
barns in addition locating a replacement
dwelling with the confines of the
residential Garden would significantly
reduce the size of the garden imunity
space for the dwelling and its young
family
Common Sense needs to be applied in this
case as the combination of all these
factors point in favor of granting
planning permission for the new dwelling
in its proposed location the current 19
century Farmhouse is extremely
dilapidated and certainly a new dwelling
in the open Countryside with an
agricultural tie would be granted
straight away in the proposed location
under under as10 so I do urge members to
vote with both their head and heart for
the young growing family in addition
there is no objection from
WCC and no change to the existing weight
collection service currently in
operation thank you
members thank you very much Council
Parry uh members do we have any
questions for our Ward
member no nothing forthcoming in which
case thank you very much
okay uh we now move on then to points of
clarification from our officers coun
Pon thank you chair can I
just clarify the question of the
residential
curtilage uh the applicant has indicated
uh a red line which is red line brry for
planning
purposes our officers able to confirm
uh for you know what the land registry
registry identifies as the residential
curtilage part of my confusion is unless
I'm misreading that the the access see
seems to go up and then dog leg left
into the property which would seem to
indicate um that the residential
curtilage is ju is not just the top
leftand box if you will so I just want
to try and get some understanding of um
because the applicant seemed to allude
to that it was a technicality that it
was outside the residential curage by
virtue of the red line boundary rather
than you know the actual uh residential
curtilage you know if you were buying or
selling the The Farmhouse and I just
wonder whether officers can help me with
that thank you so the red line was
amended to include both the land covered
by the existing dwelling and the
proposed dwelling was all the land
covered by the development had to
included within the red line that was
why that was requested so our
understanding is it's this rectangle at
the top that is the garden land
associated with the existing dwelling um
this is obviously the red line for the
application so if members were to Grant
permission tonight this would
effectively be the extent of the
gardenland associated with the dwelling
that's why we've recommended condition
um number 10 the submission of a plan
denoting the specific extent of that
Garden land because we would have
concerns I think I've raised this in the
report if the new dwelling had a
gardenland that was of this size if that
makes sense yeah um there a question
that came up at the site visit earlier
the this sort of reverse L shape that
would be the the sort of the proposed
site is 3,680 square m this rectangle at
the top is 1,621 square m so they're
quite that's somewhat in excess of the
recommended Garden sizes I think it's 62
Square met is for a four by delling um
hopefully that answers your question
somewhat coun
Harvey page 25 of the
papers refers to cs20 and provides an
extract which reads replacement
dwellings should be cited within the
lawful curtilage of the existing
dwelling unless significant
environmental benefits would
result um I note that the the extract
uses the word should be cited not must
be cited and secondly my compact Oxford
English Dictionary defines
significant as important or large enough
to be
noticed so would I be right in thinking
that a significant environmental benefit
of this project would be the
environmental benefits I.E the climate
change factors that are being met EG the
ground Source heat pump would that not
qualify as being large enough to be
noticed and
therefore the cage requirement need not
apply thank you councelor I would refer
you to the paragraph two paragraphs down
where I make an assessment of whether
these constitutes the benefits of the
application would constitute significant
benefits and I've concluded they
wouldn't um I said that the
environmental benefits of the sorry the
sustainability benefits that would arise
would be small
scale um and would not meet the
significant threshold in officers
assessment all I can say is my
definition from my Oxford English
Dictionary is important or large enough
to be noticed I I think that's obviously
up to members to decide I think in
ordinary reading of the policy
significant is quite a high bar to meet
that's all I'd
say thank thank you um I actually have a
question myself um reference has been
made to as10 I I think uh with regards
to agricultural um
accommodation um whereas what we're
looking at at the moment is replacement
dwelling which I understand would be
open market um are those
two policy points um mutually exclusive
as then could it be the case that we
would have a placement DW dwelling that
would be an agricultural dwelling or can
they not work
together I think in some instances on a
farm you might have a existing dwelling
that has an agricultural tie um and then
they might be proposing a replacement in
this instance the existing dwelling as
Council Perry mentioned dates the 19th
century so as we understand there isn't
an agricultural tie on this dwelling um
it's been submitted as a replacement
dwelling under cs20 and as10 and it's
been assessed as such so offic don't
consider that it would meet the tests to
have the agricultural toe added even
though as you say it would be an open
market dwelling but when of on the
applicant would be sort of a farmer
living there but still don't think that
that condition would be reasonable
unless Alice has anything to add on that
no I I concur I think the the point is
because the existing dwelling doesn't
have an agricultural tie on it to then
restrict the new one when they haven't
applied for that type of development to
my mind would be would be unreasonable
which would fail to meet one of the
condition
tests thank you you Council P oh sorry
Council Fleming next and
then um just a question and I know we
can only vote on what we we've got in
front of us um should this proposed
dwelling be
built what's the danger of us getting an
application in to refurbish the old one
and then sell off the new one that's
that's the only thing I my only concern
about this so if you take a look at uh
recommended sorry there's not a
recommended condition 11 this is a
condition I would recommend which I've
numbered 11 um we would put a condition
on saying that the existing dwelling
should be demolished within 3 months of
occupation of the replacement dwelling
that's a standard condition when the
sort of the footprints don't overlap for
dwellings councilor Pon thank you chair
uh can I just come back to a um you made
reference to the size of the the
garden um uh
and the question of you know a
significant expansion of domestic
Garden versus
Farm
um it would your assessment change if
there was some condition that restricted
or is it possible to restrict the size
of the garden because I I take your
point that in essence it creates a huge
um
and I'm just trying to it seems what
they've done is they've fitted around
rather than necessarily you know uh
looking for so would your assessment be
different if uh if the uh the site was
partitioned
differently I think to answer your
question I would say the officers did
suggest that the dwelling could be
located within the existing Garden lands
perhaps down here or something and the
applicant didn't didn't take up that
suggestion
so I think a condition
wouldn't obviously I'm recommending
refusal it wouldn't necessarily overcome
the issue because it's it still would be
outside the existing
gardenland thank you chair um would this
set of pres presidence uh be in outside
of the curtilage for other applications
to come along I've got no objection
about the rebuild of the house but this
is going and if it's not an agricultural
building it's in open Countryside isn't
it I just wanted to know would it set a
precedence you'll have heard this line a
lot every application on its own merits
but we still have to be conscious when
we're making decisions that they don't
set a precedent
I think there is a danger that if we
were to say that the environmental
benefits set out are significant enough
that that bar isn't hugely High
particularly if we're focusing on the
sustainability aspects because then
anyone could come in and basically say
we'll do these sustainability measures
that's significant enough to justify a
house outside the curtilage obviously in
this case we do also have the arguments
Advanced by the applicant in terms of
the proximity of the house to the farm
and I think that's probably quite Niche
and not
hugely uh repeatable across the district
so that aspect um I think would be less
dangerous in terms of setting a
precedent if that answers the
question C
Pon
apologies some of this is becoming
sequential and a trying to thought it's
just another thing that something else
comes to mind you you rightly pointed
that it we could not have an
agricultural tie as
such
however um a condition around linking
the property to the use
of um the
farm could we construct something I
think you know in other words
to presential element is inextricably
linked to the operation of the farm it's
not a I'm not looking at a tie but I
think
again it's this question about uh when
we find applications where the rationale
is the and the appeal decision in the
previous one was the rational was you
know the functional use of a caravan to
support a an agricultural business and
that kind of notion is there anything in
your professional opinion around
devising a condition that could
restrict uh because I think you know
again officers having a mind towards
this just becomes an open market
dwelling it's it's the curtilage and
there are some risks and I I know the
parish council and Ward members support
there but there are some risks around
that so mitigating those risks um is
there anything that you could advise the
committee around any form of
condition I would um as you say for the
reasons I've set out I don't think an
agricultural tire would be appropriate I
think what I would say is I'd struggle
to think of what a policy hook would be
in terms of tying the house to the
existing Farm holding next door because
it would essentially then be an
agricultural tie condition so we'd be
effectively doing the same thing I think
what I come back to in looking at this
application is that it is an open market
house at the moment so subject to that
condition if members were minded to
Grant to demolish the existing house we
wouldn't have a net increase of houses
in in an unsustainable location so we're
not as officers concerned about that
aspect it's just the sighting so I think
hopefully that should give some
reassurance we members minded to Grant
okay any further points of clarification
for our officers no in which case we can
move to debate who would like to
start interesting one keep keep
naturally looking over on this side but
I think I'll go with this side for a
change who like to start councilor
Fleming I'll go first for a change yeah
thanks for that
um struggling to find a reason to
say to agree with the officer on this
I'm I'm sort of holy minded I mean we
talk about the big Garden all his
children are under six when they're all
teenagers he's going to need a big
Garden um so you know from that
perspective um it's an improvement to
the farmsteading it keeps the guy as a
farmer for a very long time um we need
to promote agriculture in this area
we've already had a discussion similar
to that earlier um and uh it's it's an
active livestock Farm um it's what this
area is sort of noted for um so uh I
would be going against the officer's
recommendation as we stand not a
proposal but that's how I feel at the
moment thank you Council flaming who
would like to go next councelor
Harvey U thank you chairman
um logic is a funny thing uh I totally
accept that this is
um in in the open
Countryside and therefore the
presumption is generally against however
um the practicalities of this particular
house uh the existing house are such
that it it needs to be pulled down it's
it's it it doesn't provide the sort of
accommodation that you and I would want
to live in
chairman
um I think that the proposal is totally
reasonable it it
reinforces a business a successful
business um it provides accommodation
which is not
disproportional I accept that the plot
is large but so what um common sense to
me says that this is an application
which um if it was tied we would be
saying yes to it we're not tying it it
is an open market but I think in these
circumstances um and I do accept that
you can stretch significant Beyond
breaking point but neveress it's a point
worth
making um I'm in the same camp as
councelor Fleming that um despite the
arguments that the officers have put
forward I my sympathy lies with granting
this
application thank you uh councilor
passingham next
we we've recently rejected applications
because they part of just a small parts
of the garden went into open Countryside
so this would be inconsistent with that
and I can't see why that the new
proposed dwelling can't be as far away
from the farm as possible but just
inside the existing
curtilage and you could still have the
ground Source heat pump and all the
environmental benefits um and the safety
measures probably need to be put in
place anyway because it's a farm but
children have grown up on farms for
centuries and they're still doing it all
over the country
so I'm minded to uh to reject the
application on those
grounds thank you counc sorry support
support the officers whichever um yeah
so is that yeah okay yeah no got you
thank you um anyone want to follow up on
that or am I going to lend my points to
it
um I'm I'm falling on the side of
councelor passingham um but I'd like to
at least elaborate on why I think a lot
of this is absolutely acceptable in a
number of ways the issue I have is the
technicalities that's got us to where we
are that's making it unacceptable I
think we've explored those quite
thoroughly with our
officers and ultimately what one of my
predecessors has said in the past if
it's not not right it's wrong I think
there's a few tweaks to this would make
it perfectly acceptable but at the
moment we haven't got those what we have
in front of us is a red line boundary
Which is far larger than the curtilage
as it
exists
um no clarification on what the land
would what would happen to that land in
total um and the fact that it is an open
market dwelling as a result of the
existing exent permission um does make a
make an issue in terms of policy I a lot
of I've got a strong sense of feeling
that I want to Grant this because I
completely support the ideals of the
applicant um
and and their aspirations for their
family I think it's absolutely fine to
position it slightly further away from
the farm to try and improve their own
personal environment I don't however
feel that we have a policy hook to
actually justify what's in front of us
it's not something I'm happy about i'
strongly recommend the applicant take
this away make some changes and come
back before us so that we can grant
something a bit more in line with policy
at the moment I can't see it and so I'm
I'm in line with going in line with the
officer
recommendations um but expecting this to
come back so that we can approve it in a
in a reformed State that's my feeling um
I know we haven't had any proposals as
of yet I don't believe there were the
the the speeches by members who are in
favor of this have offered firm policy
grounds to go on to go against ox's
recommendations if they have them I
would invite them to bring them forward
now otherwise we're going to have to
look at proposals um which do have off
uh which do have policy basis and go
from there um I'll open up to the floor
otherwise we'll
uh can I ask a question in of um
paragraph I of
as1 why can't we justify granting on the
basis of of uh paragraph I is it simply
because the words as as written in
paragraph I do not say tied and AG
cultural it merely says permanent
dwelling for occupation by a person
engaged in an agricultural operation
which the applicant certainly is
so my justification would be paragraph I
of
as10 apart from of
course just to say it Ward memb strong
support and as strong a support from a
parish council as I've ever heard for an
application
I think as we we've discussed it hasn't
been assessed on the basis of of an
application for a roal worker you'll see
that I does require a functional need to
be established now we know the existing
occupant is a farmer but we haven't had
any evidence to confirm that there's a
functional need for an Agricultural
workers dwelling they're quite fairly
applying for a replacement dwelling I
think listening to the debate it seems
to me that members have identified those
who are minded to Grant have identified
that there are significant benefits to
reciting the dwelling outside of the
curtilage so that brings us back to
cs20 so if members were so minded to go
down that route I think that would be um
more justifiable in terms of obviously
officers assessment is the the
sustainability benefits and moving away
from the farm the active Farm is not
significant enough to meet that test
required by cs20 but members are within
their rights to come to a different
conclusion on that subject i' I'd
strongly ER away from recommending Grant
on the base of it being an agricultural
workers dwelling if we're not tying it
and I think if we're tying it then that
would be unreasonable in terms of a
condition is it open to the applicant to
come back with a a revised application
which asks for it to be
retired the difficulty with that is
they'd have to evidence the need for
they basically need to show Financial
viability that the farm is financially
stable enough to be able to support a
dwelling on the site now that just
wouldn't be logical because there's an
existing open market dwelling on the
site so it would be a lot of work for
the applicant to go through we'd have to
get it independently assessed by an
agricultural consultant to confirm that
there's a need for an Agricultural
dwelling they may come back and say
there's not but actually there's already
a dwelling on the site anyway so we're
in a bit of a awkward situation there so
I'd like I say I'd strongly suggest no I
think they they've done the the the
correct course of action in applying for
a replacement
dwelling
pimpon thank you I
think um I'm I'm not I I think if
members
want to advance the proposition to Grant
um it's got to be on the basis of a
different assessment of
cs20 and using decision makers
prerogative I don't think because I
think we've tested to destruction
whether we can find a way of shoehorning
it in with a with a policy hook and I'm
with the chair that I don't think there
is I think that he and I and the rest of
the committee
are looking for reasons to to Grant this
because I think that overall we we we
feel there is a I think the mood of the
committee would be to find a way and it
may be that if it fails at this point
you know something whereby it at least
2third straddles the sort of curtilage
kind of a thing gets the applicant home
I suspect it probably would because I
think it gives more weight in CS 20
because you know it's not absolutely
outside the cage so I think if members
are looking to find reasons they've just
got to hang their hat on a different
assessment of cs20 to that taken by the
officers um and that is that is you know
that is for each individual member to to
come to I have concerns and but bluntly
I'd like to find a way to to Grant it
but I do have concerns uh about the lack
of a policy hook but I wouldn't die in a
ditch if other members took a different
view of assessing
cs20 I'm not sure that's helpful for
anybody but I think it only in the sense
of if we if the committee is going down
this route it's on their assessment of
being different to
officers thank you councilor pton um I
mean we're we're otherwise an impass
unless somebody makes a proposition um
I'm
looking around the room otherwise I'm
going to have to make a proposal to um
refuse in line with office's
recommendations um which I will do and
seek a second I would add at this point
I thank you councelor pton um I will add
at this point that I I completely
support this application coming back
before us but in a revised form that
that is more acceptable I think there's
there's things that can be done to it
that would not make a huge material
difference to what the uh applicants put
together but in terms of policy we have
these policies for a reason councelor H
serin did raise the the point of precent
which I do think is relevant here uh and
you know it's it's a very awkward one
but I think that we all want it to
succeed and it just needs to be done in
the right way to do so um okay so that's
where we're at um unless anyone else
would like to speak uh Council
Fleming are the sufficient grounds to
defer us to let him come back with a
with a revised the revised thing or do
we have to go one way or the other with
what we' I think at this point the the
changes that I foresee and and the
officers seem to agree with uh would
require an adequately different scheme
or be that it would be a change of the
redline boundary and Etc um I don't
think the actual scheme itself would be
materially hugely different but
obviously it would have to be different
enough to to to to have a reapplication
uh so that that seems to be where we're
at uh if no one else would like to uh
contribute then we have a proposal to
refuse in line with office of
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
please
five and
against one and
abstentions one okay uh
case uh committee resolves to refuse
application
39f okay we move on then uh item six
urgent business no urgent business in
which case meeting closed thank
you